fifth sixth in the lineup they're
probably gonna have a pretty good idea
of where he's at and what he wants to
use on a given night
there you go
through an open right side beating the
shift mitch haniger face hit
[Applause]
for ariara he has given up five home
runs in the last two outings that's a
total of four and two thirds
trying to get after him early put some
pressure on him
going the other way that'll get through
into right field remember yesterday
scott service was saying
go the opposite way a lot of base hits
over there so good start here
three and one to secret couple of men on
early doings here for the mariners
bases loaded
[Applause]
up the middle bobbled
france they get him a run does score
hannigan touches up and the mariners
have a one nothing lead
solot couldn't solo couldn't handle it
cleanly
now this is a break right here playing
up the middle he hits it right to him
that would have been a double play but
instead they just get the one out and
score a run
and up the heel of his glove
pay off the gp
hit hard right to the first baseman low
throw the whole play
safe
kyle lewis beat it
let's see if they take a look at it or
not
got an under i think he did you're right
got it under
and a good angle that's a great slide
eric has had a tremendous look at it
yeah he's a perfect position to make the
call and he didn't hesitate he made it
right away hey there we go
give his choice rbi jp crawford his 11th
rbi
this one on the ground third base
ivan is the second one on the first
double play
and the inning is over so they get the
double play eventually
but not before the mariners strike for
two in the first
[Applause]
get out of the
jam that will work one of the fastest
guys on a team i don't see much of that
mike but that works
perfect
he's playing back i'm sure that dylan
just peeked down there couldn't believe
that he was playing back and
decided to drop down a bun it was a firm
bunt too
but able to get it past the pitcher and
an easy base hit another good start with
another inning for the mariners and the
abundance playing very deep
here is evan white with a swing and a
fly ball deep to left field calhoun
going back looking up and this one is
gone
into the upper deck and left evan white
with his second home run of the season
four nothing mariners
[Applause]
and here you go off speed pitch 80 miles
an hour breaking ball belt high
that is on the barrel exit velo we'll
give him 105. 421 feet
into the second deck
hopefully the rangers can
answer back here and get a run or two on
the board put a little pressure on scott
service and eric swanson
and he puts it in the air down the left
field line and that one is gone
[Applause]
this is tremendous that is big power to
hit a home run the opposite way in this
ballpark we know joey has it
and he's showing it off right there
field backed up they are playing
straight away
that's laced
into left field dylan moore starting to
pick it up
lead off double that's his fifth double
of the season
two for two day for demo in the last two
days up and down the lineup they've been
pretty aggressive here we go again
another solid line drive base hit so
evan with a couple of hits now
[Applause]
driven in three rounds
big day
forever and white five one mariners two
for two day
most of the time it was a bad start and
most of the time it stayed bad
throughout the whole year uh so you kind
of go into that grinding mode so i
really do know
when i say this i know what evan white
is feeling right now
here's joey gallo whose
opposite field home run in the second
accounts for the lone ranger run
this ball hammered center field
gallow goes straight away
and the rangers are back in it
and now his second home run of this game
but he has been on fire but we are
starting to see the ball go out of the
ballpark it certainly appears that joey
gallo is on a power run right now
audio form
this one hit sharky over third that's a
base hit here comes garcia he'll score
easily isaiah peddling for two
[Applause]
garcia was going to score easily i
thought maybe there would be a close
play it looked like isaiah put it into
another gear between first and second
and way ahead of the tag
left field to not let that ball get all
the way to the wall
showing some pretty big power 451 feet
this one into left field that's a base
hit
to start the sixth inning
second of the night
is it pretty consistent over the course
of his career this one out to the gap
right center field gets down
low
running to third base they'll stop him
there dull with a double and it's a six
game hitting streak for david
just a big spot right here all of a
sudden second and third
though there are two outs
the best pitch ground ball and that's a
base hitting the right field one is in
will send the second he scores
[Applause]
once again in a huge fight for the
rangers
look who's excited
turner's head leads two nothing
four nothing four one five one five four
now trail
high flag ball this might be the good
one right here another kyle seeger home
run in texas ties the score at 6-6
kyle gets a fastball there you go for
seamer above the belt
they knew it right away that's right on
the barrel high towering fly ball
back into the seats
17th home run
[Applause]
charlie culberson takes over third
flag ball deep to right deep to right
gone
luis terence the other way and americans
have a 7-6 lead
belt high he knew it too
impressive
dolis garcia the batter and he takes a
big hack at the first pitch deep to
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here comes davis the rangers are in
front heim with an rbi double
and he makes it eight to seven rangers
and a really good read by chris davis i
was a little bit concerned that there
was a chance of this ball getting caught
if hannigan was going to lay out he did
it
but then decided he wasn't going to get
to it so a really nice read by chris
davis to score easily on that double
2-2 on the way and that one hit trump
down the ground to shortstop they'll
come to the plate it's not a force out
he's safe culbertson slides in turns
forgot it wasn't a force
wow another run
and the rangers lead 9-7
the one two from kennedy
in the air
center field garcia was deep long run
can't get to it knocks it down one run
is in here comes the potential tying run
the third
[Applause]
another
spectacular defensive play to finish
this one and the rangers escape nine to
eight